hi folks this is joe biden
joe biden the democratic presidential
nominee
is well a little dull
but after four years of this president
trump has fired
another government watchdog disinfectant
knocks it out in a minute
dull might seem pretty appealing to
american voters right now
at the beginning of august the
economists forecast gave biden a very
high chance of winning
if he does win forget dull biden could
be the most ambitious democratic
president
for a generation this is why
all re-election bids are to a large
extent
referendums on the incumbent president
who normally has the advantage
before curved 19 hit america
president donald trump had a 50-50
chance
of being re-elected as the coronavirus
pandemic
ravaged america and as america saw
unrest and protests that it hadn't seen
since the 60s
his chance has now fallen nationally joe
biden's polling numbers are
high and they're also high in
battleground states
he's leading in the blue wall states of
wisconsin
michigan and pennsylvania states that
hillary clinton lost in 2016.
he even stands a fighting chance in
solidly republican states
such as arizona texas and georgia
pretty fly for a dull old white guy
he's clearly not an aspiring candidate
in the way that barack obama was
or even in the way that bernie sanders
or elizabeth warren work what he does
have
is a sort of wide appeal that makes him
acceptable
to the broadest possible range of voters
and one of the things that's
extraordinary about him is that he has
always sat
directly at the center of his party and
he has shifted
as his party has shifted left he has
shifted with it
a politician's ideology can be measured
based on how they vote
the closer a score is to minus one the
more left-leaning
a politician is and the closer to one
the more right-leaning
this shows the scores of all of the
democratic senators
who biden served with during his 18
congresses
the average democrat score during that
time
was minus 0.306
bidens was -0.314
placing him right in the middle of the
party
now what that means is that in this
particular election
he was not among the more progressive
candidates
that turned off a lot of progressives
but i think it signaled to a lot of
other people
that he was not radical he was not
frightening
on the other hand the fact that he has
shifted as his party shift means that he
has been open to change
so i think there's this paradox right
where progressives
want to nominate the most progressive
candidate they can but
actually there is an argument that if
you want to enact progressive policies
it's better to elect dull candidates who
are open to change
than it is to elect extremely
progressive standard bearers who are
going to frighten off a lot more people
biden's policies show he is open to
change
but that much like his candidacy it's
best achieved in a non-threatening and
gradual manner
take healthcare though biden doesn't
support the more progressive proposal of
medicare for all
he does back a government-run healthcare
program
that people can buy into now because
that program is going to be so big
it can keep premiums down it's going to
look really appealing to people who have
to buy insurance on the private market
it could eventually lead to
employers just giving their employees
money to buy insurance so that could
lead to the same place more or less that
medicare for all was leading
but in a more sort of gradual less
disruptive way
there's no more consequential challenge
than the on-rushing climate crisis
on climate change biden was lukewarm on
the green new deal
backed by those on the left but he has
proposed a two trillion dollar
environmental plan
with huge investment in green
infrastructure
he has pledged to make america carbon
neutral by 2050 so again
it's a sort of gradual plan that is no
less ambitious for being graduate
these policies set him apart from recent
democratic presidents
bill clinton was an extremely popular
president in his time
he was sort of playing on the field that
ronald reagan had set meaning there was
a sense that people were turning away
from big government
his signature policy on welfare reform
for instance
he was very tough on crime kicked a lot
of people off welfare
we have to end welfare as a way of life
and make it a path
to independence and dignity he was not
terribly progressive but that was the
field that was left to him to play
but biden is playing on a very different
field
americans appetite for federal
government intervention
changes with every presidency they are
more in favor of big government now
than at any point in the past 68 years
this gives biden the opportunity to be
more ambitious
than his predecessors
yes we can obama represented change in
who he was
but as a politician he's instinctively
cautious and he's sort of governed
really like a center-right president joe
biden
does not embody change but because he is
so widely acceptable to so many people
and because the democratic party has
moved left and because the last four
years
have been so chaotic he has the space to
govern much more ambitiously than barack
obama did
having ambitious policies is one thing
getting the legislation passed
is another to achieve that the democrats
will need to control
both the house and the senate as biden
well knows
thanks to almost five decades of
legislative experience
in 2018 democrats retook the house of
representatives
giving them a 36-seat majority but in
the senate
republicans have the majority in order
to take control of congress
the democrats will need to hold their
majority in the house
and flip at least three senate seats if
biden wins
and four if he does not and taking
control of congress
is looking possible thanks in part
dividing
[Music]
because joe biden is so broadly
appealing to so many people
he has long coattails he helps the image
of the party
there's nothing we cannot do if we do it
together
if people want to see his policies
enacted they know they have to elect a
democratic senate
and congress to do it yet a simple
majority is no guarantee
that biden would be able to pass major
legislative changes
they could be blocked by an arcane
political custom
called a filibuster
but there's another way biden could
deliver change
one which many presidents have made
liberal use of
and that doesn't require congress by
signing
executive orders
he could roll back trump's executive
orders on immigration
he can roll back the trump
administration's rollback of
environmental regulations
it's going to be tough to enact his
health healthcare plans without
legislation
but on immigration and environmental
policy there's a great deal he can do as
president without congress climate
change along with covert 19
and the iran nuclear deal are global
issues
which demand a global leader and it's in
this role
that biden could have the most
wide-reaching political effect
his vast foreign policy experience will
give him the tools to demonstrate an
ambition for true international
leadership that has been missing for the
past four years
biden was on the foreign affairs
committee in the senate for a long time
he would like to see america step back
into its role as leader of the free
world
and i think there's a sense that a lot
of democracies around the world would
like that
too and there's another way that a biden
presidency
could have an impact long beyond his own
term in office
at the age of 78 biden could be
america's oldest ever
president but he has grand plans to
future-proof
the democratic party look i view myself
as a bridge
not as anything else there's an entire
generation of leaders you saw stand
behind me
they are the future of this country
they're the people
joe biden does say that he's abridged
the next generation of democratic
leaders and what that means is
he will come into office whether he
serves one term or two terms
there'll be another generation of
democratic leaders who mature under him
he knows
he doesn't represent the future of the
party but he is the way for the future
of the party to emerge
currently biden's odds look good if you
click on the link above
it'll take you to the economist's most
up-to-date forecasting
but president trump still has time to
take decisive action on coronavirus
and carry favor with the electorate
biden could be an ambitious president
but ultimately that ambition will amount
to nothing
if he fails to win i'm jon fassman
the economist washington correspondent
to keep up to date on all the issues
shaping the 2020 election
subscribe to our checks and balance
newsletter just click on the link
opposite